salut les amis aujourd'hui filmsactu m'a
mis au défi de décrypter non pas une ni
deux ni trois ni quatre mais bien cinq
bandes annonces we5 bande annonce mais
comment va-t-il faire et qui est il
il sait mois va jeter un coup d'oeil si
tu veux je décrypte aurait en même temps
des passages toward the thunder 2
daredevil pyramide en deux et caprices
qu'après dans un espèce de bouquets
qu'ils ont dans une espèce de confiture
filmographique c'est parti mon kiki
pour la bande annonce de howard the duck
référez-vous à celle de tête de sur ma
chaise dans mes ressources de canard et
c'est la même chose
oui mais j'ai déglingué cana garde quand
même vite fait les deux passages les
plus marquants ce trailer venus
d'ailleurs htc 15ème chèque ce qui est
effrayant c'est donc un canard qui aime
le sexe et fumée qui arrive à emballer
une meuf alors que tout a pas une touche
sur les sites de rencontres notons que
ce canard avait déjà fait une apparition
dans un des films de trois frères non
aux biens il ya des blagues fm dans le
rétro or qui concerne les threads
hollander de ben stiller et owen wilson
se sont incrustés un vrai défilé en
créant une émulation incroyable
on n'avait jamais vu autant de youyous
durant une parade de cintres qui marche
les mannequins les maigres renault côté
on n'a pas de ça on est des mannequins
on est maigre
on est content vous avez vu le nedo
wayne wilson
on dirait que c'est marine ont décidé de
changer de place au milieu pour le
suivant ce sont ces yeux qui ont décidé
de changer de place puisqu'ils se sont
mis à l'intérieur de leur vie pour coter
de mardi mais aussi con qu'il est moche
c'est la bande annonce de la série
daredevil et non du film même si les
séries américaines ont maintenant
beaucoup plus de buts et que le meilleur
film française et ouais toute petite
pièce te prie pour un film français ou
une clope entrevue que je ne saurais
vous dire ok cette petite chérie il m'a
écouté que c'était millions de dollars
mardi soir
blanc que je retiens pour ce trailer
c'est celui là mec est tellement vénère
qu'il allait va péter des vitres en
retournant une table grâce à la bande
annonce du film pyramide on sait
maintenant d'où vient le virus ebola
démonstration alors surtout ne pas
l'ouvrir
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
pyramide est un mixte entre indiana
jones au et cube mais je risque fort de
perdre nos amis épileptique si je
continue les mélanges
on enchaîne donc avec le dernier extrait
retenue de caprices et ce sans
transition puisque vous verrez et un
petit clin d'oeil à l'extrême la
bande-annonce précédent regardez et un
canard qui se fait une bouffe
à part d'excusés mois pour finir on a
mixé les cinq bandes annonces et tenter
de créer une histoire cohérente
donc c'est pas gagné powell faire quand
même on l'appelle à wildegg à ces trains
je trouvais fans il semble avoir été
construit dans sa plus précis je sais
simplement de rendre la vie un peu plus
touchants m'encourage un homme seul
convaincu qu'il peut changer le monde
mon courage rester groupés et surtout ne
touchez à rien et bouna au wild west and
kelly
si cette vidéo tu as plus à ce que je
suis capable de faire des lits des
traders mais en entier alors parce que
le cd qui vous aide à faire un tour sur
ma chaîne territoire